what if I told you some of the best
Indian food in LA is next to this busy
highway at a gas station inside a
convenience store this guy certainly
likes it let's see how this plate of
Indian burritos ended up near the Dorito
aisle at the bomb bay Frankie company
you'll find Hiram and his staff making
Indian food at a gas station
hi room care to explain okay the reason
why we chose this particular gas station
is because our families actually in the
gas station give me a store business we
had this space for you for quite a while
and we thought well what a great
launchpad traditionally what you might
find it is unhealthy non fresh fare and
when you're coming across something
that's not only fresh but it's true to
the most raw ingredients so when we
start with that completely off the wall
pairing you're gonna be starting from a
really low point so all you can go is
high and higher and we're trying to just
set the bar really high since they've
opened the Bombay Frankie company has
received both critical and commercial
success definitely our most popular item
is the Frankie in Bombay sometimes it
can be a rolled-up sandwiches sometimes
it can be an enclosed sandwich what we
try to do is make it ultimately
relatable to the LA market and make it
really similar to a burrito it's one of
the best things you've ever tried people
say never mix business with friends or
family I say don't knock it until you
try it the key members of the bumpy
Frankie company it's my sister Priyanka
our esteemed chef mr. kuhmo Jeet Singh
and our staff having someone come in for
the first time who's never tried Indian
food and are completely engulfed by the
experience they truly realized that not
only is it an Indian food coming from a
gas station and being served in a gas
station that they would try it elsewhere
so by preserving traditional ingredients
tradition corporations traditional
recipes were staying true to not only
ourselves but the region of food for
which we serve and we want to make sure
that you're leaving feeling like you got
the true experience
[Music]